Any presidential appointment has the
power to change the course and
trajectory of the University. But I would
venture to say that in Carnegie Mellon's
lively history, no presidency has been
more important than the one we are about
to enter, and really for the best reasons.
And now let me take one step into the
future and introduce you the 10th
president of Carnegie Mellon University,
Farnam Jahanian.
Farnam Jahanian possesses a rare set of qualities and
experiences that make him exactly the
right leader for this university at
this extraordinary moment. And to the
extent that you know Farnam,
you know that his heart is in the work.
We dedicated our work to finding a
president who would value our unique
culture of innovation and collaboration,
leading us to build on the potential of
this moment in our history.
To accept this appointment as the next
president of this great institution in
this fantastically vibrant city of Pittsburgh.
So today, I stand here as a true believer in the
power of higher education.
I am in awe of all that you have to offer and your
dedication to making the world smarter,
safer, more equitable, and more inspiring.
I am looking forward to hearing your
dreams for shaping the world, and the
future of this great institution.
Now let's get to work.
Thank you very much.